briana how did you spend your new year
with panda
gino diana nick
oh no i actually did mine for you i
actually didn't have the two boys
um our two dogs the big ones were back
home in la
but i definitely uh diana i nick was
here and my mom has been here so it was
it was good to
you know while i was working to have
that family support
um so i didn't feel like terribly
dejected
you know and this time like everyone is
yeah and i have to tell you this film i
started crying after watching it because
it is raw it's real it brings justice to
the book
and we're going to be celebrating this
so during award season adrash your
performance is impeccable and
i just you know con congratulations to
you and having
uh women like priyanka ava duvernay as
executive producers i mean this is a big
moment
what is something like priyanka's here
advice that she gave you
that made you bring this character to
life
i think you know just uh just by being
around her on on a film set it was just
so she's just such an authentic and
genuine person
you know i mean all of us are perfectly
aware of the brilliant actor she is and
i've been a huge fan of
um her characters from uh barfi and
kamine but
just by being around her on a film site
it just felt so
light and positive that you know when
you work with
with such people then you you can just
focus on uh
on your character and just you know let
everything else fly you know
i was just entirely focused on on balzam
and
zameen as our director just gave us
incredible artistic freedom to explore
our characters and
yeah just to breathe too much life into
it you know i mean of course they're
all they're all it's based on a book
that's written by
but then i think all of us had our own
interpretations of the character
and we got um you know
our own personalities to the table and
through our experiences in life so we
found our own truth
in that and i think it was just a very
humbling experience to work with
priyanka
yeah and priyanka i'd be pinky too man
the way she's treated and just the you
know just the mentality of some
the way women are treated in india but
it got me thinking you were born in
india
and you go into this industry when was
that pivotal moment where you were
respected
and you were heard let me tell you one
thing though that is not
the way women are treated in just india
that's the way women are
treated right let's just clarify that
statement is that we have to work four
times harder to prove a point
um we have to demand respect we don't we
you know
um we have to make sure that it's given
to us and we
we have to stand our ground and we have
to be tougher
um and i think that you know
um for me as well respect was something
that
i never sort of tried asked for
um i put my head down and i worked and i
let my work
dictate the respect that i would get and
whenever i was denied
something because i'm female or you know
treated a certain way because i was
female i stood up for it and um that was
something that my parents
raised me as they've raised me
opinionated and my parents
indian and i was raised in india
i am an amalgamation of um you know
modern india and it's uh it's urban
urban sensibility and you know
traditional india
um also both of them so
you know respect is something that you
have to demand especially for a female
and i was really raised with that
i love that i love that and the timing
of releasing this film is very
interesting with everything that's
happening in india
with the farmer's protests you know
democracy we've been talking about that
what are your thoughts on what's
happening right now is the kind of a
reflection of what india is going
through
in terms of corruption i think it's it's
a
first of all i want to establish that
this movie movie was
this book was written in the turn of the
century which is like
top of two thousands you know um it's
2005-ish
it was a very different india that this
movie is it's not reflective of the
india that is now
india has made massive strides um from
where
we were at that time but that time in
the book it was such an interesting time
because india was its precipitate of
being the news of economic superpower
and yeah
like balram's character says it was a
time of the brown man and the yellow man
and um i think the the class disparity
that this movie talks about is the most
universal thing um about this film
anywhere you go in the world people are
poor and people are rich
and the socio-economic divide is getting
larger and larger
we as people are getting um you know
sort of desensitized
to things that make us uncomfortable and
as filmmakers the only thing we can do
is use our medium
to create stories that you know become a
mirror to society and not just a society
in asia but society around the world
um it's something that we need we need
to discuss this
large middle class that exists in the
world and this huge population of people
that don't have the opportunities that a
lot of people do and how are we going to
create those opportunities
so i'm really proud of being attached to
this movie as an ep because
it um it creates an uncom conversation
and without conversation they'll never
be changed
oh i love that finally what's your
favorite indian cuisine because i was
craving indian food while watching this
film
adarsh is an amazing cook he has a few
well sangeeta if you ever make it to jim
shaitpur where i was born and where
priyanka was born
my mother is from like she currently
works in kim shaidpur
and you've got to come and have her loki
kofta oh
it's so amazing i have to tell you it's
so amazing and i've tried my
hand it like making it but obviously i'm
not as half as good as my mother but
what
i can make really well is a mushroom
capsicum curry so if you're ever in
bombay
i'd love to host you in my house and i'd
love to feed you someone
i'm more like a consumer of
food rather than a creator of it but
give me aloo parantha any day
and i would be very happy i'm training
for a new job right now so it seems
really really far away in my future
i will dream about it tonight
oh it gets me all hungry uh good seeing
all of you priyanka hey to dana for me
take care everybody
bye guys
you